m
clairefontaine dans les yvelines au mois
de janvier dernier
c'est le tout premier rassemblement de
l'année pour les joueuses de l'équipe de
france au fameux centre national du
football
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans un peu plus de 100 jours débutera
la compétition la plus importante de
leur carrière
la coupe du monde
organisé pour la première fois en france
dimanche 7 juillet stade de niort il
fait beau vous entrée sur la pelouse la
france est en finale face à l'équipe de
votre choix
fermez les yeux raconté la suite
[Musique]
ça va être simple alors on sera finale
contre qui
brésil parce que c'est le france brésil
m'a donné envie de jouer au foot et
j'imagine déjà l'ambiance on est apte ou
non à son maillot bleu-blanc-rouge
serait quand ma culture on arrive à
marquer un premier but
génial 1 0 à la mi temps c'est bien on
retourne sur le terrain après la mi
temps et on marque un deuxième but
minutes après la mi temps on a 2 0 il
reste 5 minutes on attend les cinq
minutes avec suspense et puis pour faire
un petit souvenir de 98 le troisième but
à la fin et pleure son sont là
il ya plein d'émotions je pense
[Musique]
et voilà on est championne du monde
[Applaudissements]
nous allons vivre les derniers mois de
préparation aux côtés de ses joueuses
qui rêvent de décrocher une première
étoile
emmenés par leur capitaine amandine
henry et leur buteur vedette jimmy le
sommaire considérée comme l'une des
meilleures joueuses au monde et yoro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est tôt je me suis donné les moyens de
réussir et très tôt j'ai vu j'ai voulu
en faire mon métier en fait même si ça
n'existait pas
ces bleus là ont pourtant bien failli ne
jamais avoir le droit de jouer au foot
parce que c'étaient des filles et parce
qu'une fille ça ne joue pas au foot trop
violent trop physique
sage au début
je me disais c'est une fille bien des
scènes est le parfait la desserte au
stade
à force de courage et de détermination
ils ont prouvé le contraire elles ont
vaincu les préjugés nous les suivrons
chez elle auprès de leurs familles et de
leurs proches dans les coulisses de
l'équipe
ne lâchez rien dans leur quête d'un
premier sacre mondial
il s'applique désormais
[Musique]
leur aventure a commencé au coeur de
l'hiver
premières convocations à clairefontaine
pour préparer leur première rencontre
face aux championnes américaines
les tenantes du titre un premier test
pour se situer
[Musique]
en trois participations
les bleus ne sont jamais parvenus à se
hisser sur le podium
cette année sera-t-elle la bonne
[Musique]
cinq rencontres de préparation sont
prévus d'ici le mois de juin cinq
rencontres pour former la meilleure
équipe possible
une trentaine de joueuses seront
convoqués seuls 23 disputeront la
compétition
la liste sera annoncée un mois avant la
cérémonie d'ouverture
la première fois que je les ai vus jouer
j'ai été surpris parce que je ne me
ferai pas une idée de ce qu'elle pouvait
faire non seulement ils ont du cran mais
elles sont rapides la plupart de moitié
qui sont là ans déjà et ils changent que
même pas mal d'hommes le procès de porc
vous at-on déjà dit où avez vous déjà
entendu dire que le foot ce n'était pas
un sport pour une fille bah j'ai à peu
près entendu toute ma jeunesse on va
dire
c'était quasiment tous les jours je
pense
à ça je l' ai beaucoup entendu ma mère
m'a justement n'était pas pour onet mois
au début elle était pas pour me disais
ans qu'il prend avec qui tu fasses mal
j'ai pas envie que ça soit trop violent
pour toi tu vas être qu'avec des garçons
ça n'a pas été évident mais de l'autre
côté avec mon père mon père et mon frère
qui disent non enfin si elle aime à peu
pour qu'elle continue et au fur et à
mesure ma mère elle me voyait jouer m
servat mais quand même ça vas tu je suis
quand même au ballon et tout même si
elle connaissait pas trop mais bon elle
cessa match et joue comme une ballon
on voit que tu aimes ce que tu fais quoi
je crois que c'est un sport assez
violent et je porte les sports violents
doivent être en principe interdit aux
femmes il ya quand même une différence
de l'ortolo j entre un homme et une
femme qui nous apprend rien bon la
première celle et cela et je pense que
l'état qui est dangereux et ses
demoiselles refuse de se protéger les
salles et traumatismes du salé un choc
assez violent sur le sein des décors ben
d'hématomes déjà quand j'arrive dans une
équipe les regards et c'est vrai que
le plus que j'ai entendu c'est ça c'est
ou quand j'arrivais contre une équipe
avec mon équipe donc j'étais avec les
garçons mes copains ça se passait super
bien et eux ils ne défendent est au
contraire et quand on est arrivé au
match contre une autre équipe qui on
connaissait pas et 10 heures le foot
c'est pas pour les filles c'est que pour
les garçons tu sais pas jouer au foot et
cetera et cetera c'est bon on a gagné
les gars là c'était ce genre de
réflexion j'ai bien entendu les équipes
adverses dire y'a des filles dans
l'équipe c'est bon on va les battre
alors que c'est nous qui avons gagné et
je pense que si nos maux de tête on est
on est pas prête et on n'a pas forcément
envie d'aller loin ça peut nous faire
ralentir ou s'arrêter j'étais la seule
fille là où j'habite et j'étais là
j'étais la seule fille à jouer au foot
mais appréciée par un problème je peux
m'imposer c'est pas grave aucun moment
je me suis dit bon ben ça doit pas être
fait pour les filles au contraire ça m'a
ça m'a poussé à vouloir être encore
meilleurs pour montrer que massy et
s'ils pouvaient jouer au foot
y oui l'histoire du foot féminin c'est
l'histoire d'un long combat contre les
préjugés la première fois le football
est-il encore d'un milieu misogyne oui à
sans hésitation
sans hésitation mais
comme dans la vie on ne peut pas plaire
à tout le monde
donc j'ai envie de dire c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave tant que nous
enfin surtout mes joueuses aujourd'hui
puissent
vivre de leur passion exercer leur
passion que moi aujourd'hui je puisse
vivre de ma passion aussi parce que très
sincèrement il ya quelques années et je
n'imaginais même pas à gagner de
l'argent en entraînant une équipe de
foot je pense malheureusement que ça va
encore durer un petit peu même si très
sincèrement la société d'aujourd'hui a
beaucoup évoluer les mentalités évoluent
mais on part de tellement loin que
on a réussi
deux par le jeu de par les résultats
malgré tout de nos clubs de par
l'investissement de nos clubs
aujourd'hui on a réussi à inverser un
petit peu cette tendance chez certains
mais on part de tellement loin que
y en a encore beaucoup à convaincre
pourtant c'est bien une révolution qui
se produit en moins d'un demi siècle
aujourd'hui non seulement les filles
jouent au foot mais surtout elles
peuvent vont vivre une dizaine de clubs
professionnels ont vu le jour les plus
importants comme lyon ou comme ici paris
fournissent à eux deux l'essentiel des
joueuses de l'équipe de france
grâce généraux et l'une d'entre elles
nouveau visage des bleus à 21 ans elle
espère faire partie de la sélection
finale de corinne diacre
nous l'avons suivi à orléans où elle a
grandi avec sa soeur et ses frères qui
voulait faire d'elle une championne
seyyam l'aîné qui lui a mis son premier
ballon entre les mains
son père pasteur la compagnie à tous ses
matches quant à sa mère elle a mis du
temps à accepter la passion de sa fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne parle n'importe quel
fait quand même trois ans quand même
parce qu'au début ça ça m'énervait je
voulais garder mais ces résumés de match
et
garder ça m'énerve et je m'énervais se
monte maintenant là je connais tous même
les équipes qui m'ont je suis tout chez
les garçons chez les filles franchement
n'importe quel match à saint-etienne
bordeaux
du moment depuis quand des plus
crédibles je suis là parce que c'est pas
le choix comme hier et avait maté voulu
mettre le fumier lennon mettait le match
à paris qui joue donc à
[Rires]
l'image de tous moi je me disais c'est
une fille
tout en aidant avec son frère et moi ça
m'énerve parce qu'elles devaient faire
la vaisselle quand j'ai la chance d'être
au stade et quand je monte la barre aux
escaliers dans ma maison dans la chambre
là bas je vois le style tôt fait crasse
que tu fais tu as laissé la vaisselle
dont elle ne voulait rien entendre et
c'est ça qui met des buts tu n'auras pas
le corps du fils ne sera pas fait mine
et tu pourras pas te maquiller ce que tu
seras une fille garçon quoi moi j'ai
vraiment pour moi c'était ça mon
problème je voulais pas qu'elle soit une
fille garçon mais heureusement on ne dit
jamais assez micky et les féminines
je vais dit sagan de trois ans
j'avais peur j'ai des séracs bracket
voit des débats réforme câble moi c'est
pas con tu veux pas mettre une robe
comme vite se serait pas bon c'était ça
mon souci
offert des petits cons que faire la
vaisselle
en fait en fait je n'avais besoin de
toujours de toucher de ballon sorti avec
mon frère de toujours marquer des buts
et c'est comme ça et quand ma mère à
nous et fait la vaisselle en fait
j'avais l'hameçon je perdais du temps en
fait je me trouvais pas ma place
à l'âge de 8 ans grâce s'inscrit à lui
assure lyon un club manifestement peu
habitués à voir les filles se présenter
pour jouer et je suis arrivé je me
rappelle c'était celui qui s'occupait de
l'accueil et mike reid m'a dit bonjour
c'est pour les humains en bourse pour le
foot il fait d'accord pour votre frère
ou ça vous venez prendre les
inscriptions chez nombre je veux faire
du flottement vous elle était choquée il
m'a dit mais mais on n'a pas de fille
qui font du foot ici j'ai dit oui mais
je jouais les garçons à bons mais ils
étaient franchement ils étaient ils
étaient surpris et puis madiba moyens
pas tout sinon je veux juste voir à
calais coach je vous donnerai des
papiers quand est ce qu'elle est
détection et vous viendrez et puis bah
c'est parti de là je suis arrivé à cette
époque avait trente trente cinq garçons
et j'arrive au milieu des trente cinq
garçons pas facile à
[Musique]
bbb
mais ça c'est salam qui est amusant
c'est marrant régal toi moi
né au congo grâce débarque à orléans à
l'âge de deux ans
c'est là qu'elle vivra toute son enfance
une enfance heureuse et studieuse et
beaucoup de temps passé dans les
transports en commun pour se rendre à
l'entraînement
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le stade était fermé on voulait
tellement je
mets ma taille n'est ouvert mais souvent
avant il était fermé on aimait bien pas
celle ci a sauvé des matchs et
franchement c'est être
même été des petits ponts et au bti si
elles étaient des petits coins des papas
de 30 ans ils avaient des enfants à la
maison
j'habite là bas moi
et ma mère elle nous regarde pas non
mais là encore les arbitres cachemire
avant elle n'est pas tous ces arbres ça
veut dire qu'elle me voyait même quand
j'étais pas la maison elle m'appelait
par la grâce votre vélo
c'était ça serait ça te met trop de
maintenir le début au début j'aimais
comme grâce à un goal et je n'oublierai
jamais on s'entraînait aussi sur les
transversales web par exemple celle à
aller là bas je fais pied gauche pied
droit pied gauche pied droit parce que
moi j'ai compris que dans le foot si
t'as pas les deux pieds c'est très
compliqué et moi je voulais qu'elle soit
vraiment performante parce que pour une
fille je voulais qu'elle fasse la diff
je veux qu'elle fasse carrément la
différence je veux que en fait thomas
tisseyre ajouts c'est comme si c'est un
garçon qui joue qu'à sont quand même
plus fort que les garçons c'est ça que
je veux j'ai donné toute mon énergie à
ma petite sarah et là je suis vraiment
faire -prendre
cette école à variateur footballeuses
baisse en fait moi je me rends pas
compte en fait c'est vraiment une
footballeuse et que c'est vraiment une
star est des fois me go
est un
tout et tout alors que moi quand je la
vois la météo je fais mais y est c'est
grâce à
je vais de certaines mesures si ma soeur
c'est pas une star lh2 kouf
ce qui importe c'est vrai nom mais à la
maison je suis sincère en fait
je veux faire des têtes bien ça vient
faire les têtes
ok mais pas toutes trois là ok
[Musique]
retour à clairefontaine pour le premier
match de préparation face au redoutable
et américaines les championnes du monde
en titre
le match a lieu au havre dans 48 heures
[Musique]
les etats unis c'est la mecque du foot
féminin le pays du soccer au sport
féminin par excellence toutes les filles
s'y met dès le plus jeune âge
[Musique]
la capitaine des bleues amandine henry a
tenté l'aventuré elle a joué une saison
dans le club de portland elle a même été
sacrée championne des etats-unis avec
son équipe
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup appris humainement parce
que c'est une superbe expérience celui
des choses que tu aies jamais vu
auparavant un management différent un
jeu différent et je mange en sort grandi
parce que ça te fait mûrir un déjà est à
la barrière de la langue dont tu
apprends tu apprends aussi à prendre du
recul enfin a pas baissé la tête quand
tu auras une passe ou un match ça arrive
et ouais c'est ça a été une superbe
excellente
[Musique]
à 24 heures du coup d'envoi dernier
entraînement dans le stade où aura lieu
la rencontre
le lendemain quelques minutes avant le
match amandine henry va retrouver ses
anciennes coéquipières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
dire bye bye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui nous importe
c'est gentil ce score à la mi temps
c'est gentil
mccoy bon moyen d'avoir deux mais c'est
bien pour elle mais le ton deuxième mi
temps ce degré d'accord faut redémarrer
la deuxième mi temps tambour battant
quand vous allez faire en première ne
lâchez rien n'a rien
encore avec
il y avait un banc déclare il est
toujours là avec qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les cartes
[Applaudissements]
les reflets et marcel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis ravi de vous accompagner dans
cette aventure j'espère que au mois de
juin et puis dans tous les matchs que
vous ferez avant ben vous serez aussi
bonne que ce soir et je serai je suis
ravie d'accord avec vous là et
félicitations à quoi
[Applaudissements]
lambersart dans le nord
écartée car tes cartes et car nous avons
retrouvé les images du tout premier
match officiel d'amandine henry la
capitaine des bleues
à l'âge de 5 ans j'ai demandé à mon père
de m'inscrire au foot et puis bah voilà
ça a commencé comme ça
à lui m'a toujours soutenue pour mibr
son fils seul importe peu tant que je me
sentais épanouie et que ce fait j'étais
heureuse voilà c'était plus important
derrière la caméra yves son père agent
postal est lui aussi joueur du club les
héros du film
c'était compliqué de filmer puis de
regarder en même temps quoi c'est pour
ça que la qualité d'image je pense pas
qu'elle ait pas de ciel pas terrible ça
va c'était compte en mer sert justement
son club sans savoir qu'elle allait
passer allant vers ça puis ça finit par
2 à 0 0
[Rires]
[Musique]
elle était passionnée j'avais mis mon
cousin qui jouent au foot mon père qui
était passionné de foot j'aime bien et
j'habitais dans un stade de foot aussi
mais moi j'ai toujours été passionné
j'avais une balançoire dans le jardin
pas je m'amuse à faire des buts vous a
grimpé enfin pas des sports pas des
choses qu'une petite fille faisait
normalement quand on joue encore au
football
ma compagne est toujours avec son ballon
comme samedi après midi jouer et puis
quand on allait voir les produits losc
elle venait aussi aux au match des fois
le s'endormaient dans mes bras
après son passage dans le club de
lambersart à 10 ans et tente d'intégrer
celui de lille qui refusent de
l'inscrire parce que c'était une fille
et qu'elle n'avait pas d'avenir
à l'école on me disait que
elle pouvait pas devenir professionnel
que ça n'existait pas qui disait si je
veux être professionnel puisse et ses
professeurs ou si c'est petite école ils
disent et non ça n'existe pas l'alizé si
je veux y arriver
et c'est à hénin-beaumont qu'elle va
arriver à ses fins elle tape dans l'oeil
du sélectionneur régional déjà
visionnaire à l'époque
du football à proprement parler elle
sait déjà tout faire que ce soit sur le
plan technique le plan de principe des
jeux surtout à une maturité
excellente pour une fille de cet âge
quoi c'est quoi son avenir
moi je la vois l'équipe de france ça
c'est clair et puis bon de par sa
personnalité avec un rôle de cadre au
bout peut-être le capitaine ou mais ça
c'est pas moi qui en décident donc vous
me permettrez de garder un peu la
réservation
depuis huit mois donc c'est devenu une
habitude chaque dimanche amandine part
pour paris
je pensais pas que ce serait aussi dur à
15 ans elle prend son envol elle quitte
ses parents pour intégrer le centre de
formation de clairefontaine
au revoir ces images ouais ça fait chaud
les bons souvenirs oui nous aimons mois
pleins d moment un peu délicat c'était
compliqué
balla qu'elle quitte la maison
le dimanche le soir sans savoir parce
qu'elle rentrait tard si le trajet avait
bien se passer
et ont été reçus une fois qu'elle était
bien arrivé dans sa chambre à
clairefontaine
le fait de partager temps en temps le
week-end avec mes parents et mes amis
disent pas facile oui les moments durs
parce qu'il a fallu se faire accepter et
puis on est dans la peur d'adolescence
donc on se cherche un peu
les gars ont commencé à s'intéresser aux
filles nous les moi personnellement je
pensais qu'au foot donc ça et puis des
fois battu 2e tu dois choisir ton quand
est-ce que je reste et que les garçons
où est ce que je me forçais que les
filles je combine des fois aussi 20 tu
dois devenir un peu plus femme donc tu
vois un peu
prendre soin de toi faire attention
comme un petit avis et ouais c'est de
transition n'a pas été facile mais en
partant de la fontaine en fait le fait
d'être en internat et de rester qu'avec
les filles ça m'a beaucoup aidé de
commencer ici elle fait l'apprentissage
du haut niveau le centre vient d'ouvrir
une section féminine pour les meilleures
joueuses de l'hexagone
les bêtises à la maison pas de trop pas
de trop c'est la fontaine surtout quand
c'est fait surprendre en train de manger
un kebab dans sa chambre elle se faisait
livrer je pense qu'elle s'est fait
prendre en plus justement c'était madame
roujas je pense qu'elle a eu un
avertissement d'ailleurs deux fois s'est
fait prendre
deux fois deux fois pour ok bah oué pitt
sera tout comme ça quoi donc on avait
des courriers comme quoique
fallait que cameron et une réagissent
que ça se faisait pas
et manger des pâtes tous les jours c'est
compliqué
soto convient dit là on aime bien les
frites
elle intègre l'olympique lyonnais en
2007 le professionnalisme se développe
dans les clubs
amandine a 17 ans quand elle signe son
premier contrat toujours plus dur la vie
d'une jeune espoir du foot est loin de
ressembler à un conte de fées
je pense que j'ai une bonne étoile parce
que je suis une bonne génération
j'ai fini ma formation et là on a
proposé les contrats professionnels
tandis qu'avant - bayal est pionnière
elle est malheureusement l on pas que tu
vivre de leur passion de jean dû
travailler l'entraînement performante
elle on limite elle devait faire un
choix tandis que ben non pas du tout je
suis arrivé j'ai fini ma formation j'ai
signé à l'ol homs est devenu
professionnel et ça j'en suis
reconnaissante par rapport aux autres
aux autres filles qui n'ont pas eu cette
chance parce que devoir choisir entre sa
passion et son métier c'est compliqué
les pionnières ce sont ces joueuses qui
ont essuyé les plâtres qui se sont
lancés malgré les préjugés les
réticences et le machisme ambiant celles
qui ont dû faire signer une autorisation
leur mari pour avoir le droit de jouer
à la fin des années 60 des équipes se
montrent dans l'est de la france
notamment à reims et ce sont les
rémoises qui vont montrer la voie à
toute une génération jose
les gens et des entraîneurs les
pionnières sont présentes ce soir là
fédération française de football laurent
hommage
[Musique]
le voilà
[Applaudissements]
avec grand bonheur
à l'épreuve nos photos non
[Rires]
c'est pas ça vient c'est une chance et
un privilège
du bras contre les listes
on était exceptionnel basse et
pour moi ces chapeaux mobilisables
maîtres en argent et puis avion cette
exposition à l'élite elle est inhérente
donc elle a passé un peu partout les
gens en deux ans il fenêtre de toit
cette équipe de france et pas juste en
2010 9 me en 2011 c'est bien avant et à
la fiction qui ont fait le boulot avant
nous qui ont eu des moments compliqués
parce que c'était chose de foot
aujourd'hui c'est leur dire ouais bah
merci laurent voulzy par an je tiens à
dire que cette photo a été réalisée sans
trucage on était en stage à tignes c'est
moi c'est important de le dire
mais sans trucage oui c'était vous des
vies pas droit de jouer c'est ça on
était on attend on a été interdit de
terrain n'avait pas le c'était les
femmes s'étaient pas dans la cuisine
n'est pas dans l'est sur le terrain donc
ça a été je pense difficile à vivre pour
celles qui l'ont vécue pour celles qui
ont eu la chance d'intégrer et avoir
cette tolérance et ouverture d'esprit da
par deux des clubs masculins parce qu'il
n'y avait pas encore de deux sections
féminines c'est plutôt une chance et
aujourd'hui on a su surfer sur cette
chance surfer sur ce respect pour un
nouveau nous profiter de tout ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
les femmes jouent au foot depuis le
siècle dernier la première équipe de
france et créé en 1920 mais il faudra
attendre un demi siècle pour qu'un
championnat voit le jour les pratiquants
de sont rares aujourd'hui on ne lésine
pas sur les moyens pour en attirer plus
depuis 2011 la fédération a lancé un
plan de féminisation du foot français à
grand renfort de campagnes publicitaires
comme celle ci
[Musique]
l'objectif dépassé le cap des 200 mille
licenciés d'ici 2020 et rattraper le
retard par rapport à d'autres pays comme
l'allemagne qui en compte plus non
mignot
tous les clubs comptent désormais une
section féminine en 1970 il y avait à
peine 2000 football aux en france elles
sont plus de 150 me aujourd'hui
à laval on attend de pied ferme les
bleus qui vont rencontrer l'allemagne ce
soir
toute l'école de foot du club est
mobilisé
ses jeunes joueuses ont été choisis pour
être ramasseuse de balle ont pendant le
match
je compte sur vous pour la ponctualité
et puis essayer de rester dans
l'euphorie certes mais mes concentrait
surtout p toutes les commandes dire les
règles qu'on va vous donner et j'espère
que l'on va passer un super moment avec
l'équipe de france est allée la france
genre
c'est
à fermer vos sacs
[Musique]
je pense qu'un jour juste d'entre elles
peut devenir championne du monde
mais c'est de rêver pour l ouais
j'espère en faire sortir le nommant au
moins une que tout l'effectif que je
peux avoir vous auriez envie de jouer
pour l'équipe de france un jour ça
sandra sassine objectif je crois
quand tu vois quand tu vois un stade
comme ça ça donne envie
j'aimerais bien tes brevet est en plein
milieu là être la jouerie ce qui pourra
petit parti mon
kiki ferais tu viens cancale célébration
si vous y allez
aujourd'hui c'est
le plus beau métier couche plus avoir
longuement
rose avec les petites piscines au
système dans notre stade c'est
extraordinaire d'accueillir l'équipe de
france
m
[Musique]
moi cela
j'avais tout ravi on trinque la 7ème dan
tremplin centre
[Musique]
amis
18 heures arrivée des joueuses conduite
par leur entraîneur corinne diacre
les bleus vont découvrir les nouveaux
maillots spécial coupe du monde qu'elles
vont étrenner ce soir
je
jacky ballon à l'entrée des jeux
[Applaudissements]
mais ça qu'ils la choix
elle affronte un adversaire de taille
l'allemagne qui a déjà remporté deux
coupes du monde
[Musique]
l'allemagne comme pour les garçons c'est
la bête noire des bleus c'est l'équipe
qui a éliminé la france en quarts de
finale lors du dernier mondial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rencontre est très fermé les
françaises n'arrive pas à prendre
l'aventage et ce sont finalement les
allemandes qui marque le seul but du
match
c'est terminé moment historique c'est au
tour des qualifs
[Musique]
la pulsion les grosses compétitions ça
joue à des détails elles sont pas eu
beaucoup d'occasions mais presque la
seule case on la met au fond donc voilà
on sait qu'il faut encore travailler
n'avait pas mal de victoires mais
bassano mis les pieds sur terre on sait
que voilà entend on encore quelques mois
pour peaufiner encore quelques détails
dans une semaine les bleus auront
l'occasion de se rattraper face à
l'uruguay leur prochain adversaire
[Applaudissements]
je vais y aller quand je les ai vus et
sous la
voir comme ça
ça va les voir avec les hauts cris green
et une ça m'a fait un petit pincement
[Musique]
c'est parti vient bien aller dès le
lendemain les bleus se remettent au
travail les avis la star eva roy joue
avec ton corps sans faire faute
la séance d'entraînement est ouverte au
public
parmi les joueuses qui s'arrêtent pour
signer des autographes
il y à la jeune attaquante
viviane asei elle est entrée en jeu dans
les dix dernières minutes face à
l'allemagne mais n'a rien pu faire
le mat il est passé
du match qu'on a fait hier mais toujours
le travail dans la tête
viviane oci c'est d'ici qu'elle vient le
petit-quevilly à côté droit
[Musique]
saison ce club qu'elle a commencé à
jouer
ça en fait
vous êtes prête pour jouer les contres
les garçons
aujourd'hui elle est devenue la marraine
de la section féminine qui grossit année
après année
[Applaudissements]
ce jour là les joueuses de moins de 17
ans rencontrent les garçons de
pont-audemer
sur les bords du terrain une supportrice
donne de la voix la maman de viviane
c'est elle qui inscrit sa fille au club
beaucoup beaucoup de fois parce que ça
contient donc
la moindre faille j'avais droit à me
faire engueuler
[Musique]
vous voulez je dis pas ce que j'ai vu
ici d'aller le lendemain de
ce que j'ai vu
c'est pas une majorité mais sa
technologie et monsieur le joueur 3 nra
laisser le frame a donné lundi et
hier matin à
risque parce que je suis bénie j'ai dit
écoutez moi ma fille en est où est trop
petit ou en revenait j'ai dit pour
monter les lions va la tester nos
maîtres evian va la tester ok je vois
passer un petit bout
ils ont bien dû au fait nous
on appelle l acid and est ici là il
anticipe nommé effet petit cancer et aux
prisonniers lagarde d'aucuns dit.il on
garde à kelly laissé cinq ans jusqu'à
présent a transporté la shoah c'est
complètement égal les bottines des
zidane quand j'avais j'avais des crampes
aux williams et de coordination
non mais vide garé d'électro à la maison
et puis on me dit je ne suis pas un
enfant comme ça j'ai dit et s'il était
aussi et dans son truc laisserait ses
crampons mais quand tu pars confusion
oui toujours un axe un truc première
médaille elle jouera à rouen et se fera
connaître en marquant autant de buts que
deux matchs joués un exploit
puis ce sera un montpellier marseille et
enfin bordeaux son club actuel
[Musique]
se relever après tout vous dise le volet
vouloir pour ça je dis que c'est dans la
tête c'est mental vous êtes
allés à l'école ils vous disent allez
quand même encore matin une visite je
sais pas jouer au foot et pas avant il
faisait tu sais pas jouer au foot et
tout va j arrête tout ça et dès que je
voulais jouer dans la cour avec les
garçons et où j'étais la seule fille à
jouer
vos fichiers je m'en fiche et je jouais
et déjà commencé à mais d une carte du
monde et oisillons prendre les vessies
t'inquiète je laisse la place
à un exposé j'ai enfin l'exposition vous
sur
vin est un modèle pour vous les filles
willem côté perso
j'ai pas moi c'est en double à part
l'ajout de huy
ainsi à tout moment vraiment j'espère
bien d'être là mais je vous vois en est
là on soulève la coupe et où j'ai dit
hier courte labat angeli là quand ça va
venir d'abord la liste a dit non je te
jure que ce groupe là tu vas voir on va
aller la chercher
[Musique]
en attendant pour la petite histoire les
moins de 17 ans féminines ont finalement
battu les garçons de pont-audemer
sur le film
[Musique]
mallet
[Applaudissements]
olé dallas
il ya des victoires qui veulent toutes
les coupes du monde
[Applaudissements]
le club compte 50 fois plus de licenciés
depuis que viviane a montré la voie
celle d'une carrière qui peut mener
jusqu'à l'équipe de france
[Applaudissements]
retour sur les terrains avec maeva
clemaron milieu de terrain diplômé bac
+5 et très grande copine de viviane
pas trois ferries
ses cheveux
on se ressemble à la fin des formateurs
pare feu
naturel couleurs nationales sourire ça a
l'air de bien fonctionner dans
[Musique]
l'histoire du cheveu voilà ouais c'est
une évidence à ce parcours matière mais
je vais rouler à houleh et on est sûr
c'est vrai un jeu étrange et
laisser melox avec votre couple
il faut à notre
bien on va essayer de pas faire long
mais d'être efficace l'uruguay devrait
jouer très regroupée très bas même si
par moments elle presqu'au mais de
manière très désorganisés mais on va
continuer à travailler ce qui est le
plus difficile c'est à dire les attaques
placées dans les tran cardio
avec toujours des appels dans la
profondeur propre et surtout de la
finition avec des duels un contre un
avec un gardien
un mot pour qualifier votre équipe
[Musique]
travailleuse
il reste trois mois avant le début de la
compétition
trois mois et trois rencontres pour
former la meilleure équipe possible
[Musique]
un mot pour vous qualifier comme
entraîneur
exigeante
mais
alors ça c'est vrai que certaines
personnes voient ça comme quelque chose
de enfin tout cas les gens me voient
comme quelqu'un de très directif très
autoritaire mais en fait je suis aussi
exigeante avec les joueuses que je n'ai
reçu avec moi même c'est à dire que je
ne leur imposons rien que je ne m'impose
pas
[Musique]
corinne diacre a pris les rênes de
l'équipe en 2010 est
discrète et déterminé
c'est une ancienne joueuse
internationale la première femme à avoir
entraîné l'équipe masculine
professionnels
après les états unis et l'allemagne
l'équipe de france va affronter
l'uruguay une équipe réputée plus faible
l'occasion pour corinne diacre de faire
tourner son effectif et de donner leur
chance à de jeunes joueuses moins
expérimentées
sur un match elles peuvent faire la
différence et gagner leur place dans la
sélection finale
quelles qualités recherchées vous
lorsque vous sélectionnez une chose
tout d'abord la performance sur le sur
le terrain avec son club
une fois qu'elle est avec nous en équipe
de ce national la performance aussi sur
le terrain avec nous est ce qu'elle est
capable d' hausser son niveau de jeu est
ce qu'elle est capable de se mettre au
niveau de l'équipe de france est ce
qu'elle est capable de se mettre au
niveau des exigences qu'impose le haut
niveau
voilà il ya tout ça après il ya l'aspect
technique tactique
un peu aussi le psychologique mais en
fait c'est un tout si un tout mais
et puis après il n'y a pas que la
joueuse en elle-même il ya comment cette
performance là va s'articuler avec
celles qui vont être autour d'elle donc
parce que pour au final faire un
collectif une une minute allait minutes
m
[Applaudissements]
parmi les joueuses qui espère briller ce
soir
nous retrouvons maeva clemaron
elle est remplaçante et pourrait entrer
en deuxième mi temps elle n'est pas
certaine d'être retenu pour disputer la
coupe du monde elle doit tout faire pour
gagner sa place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le match débute et c'est un festival
offensif les bleus ouvrent le score et
viviane asei puis elle déroule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
centré ses deux le soir et celui là pour
mettre le troisième
[Applaudissements]
c'est le quatrième but sera marqué
par grace geo
[Applaudissements]
6 puis si pour le la rencontre tourne à
la démonstration de la gardienne s'est
passé
[Applaudissements]
vingt minutes de la fin la france mène 5
à 0 la capitale amandine henry cède sa
place à maeva clemaron c'est seulement
sa troisième sélection chez les bleus
tous avec
et elle veut inscrire son tout premier
but en équipe de france
il ya du vent
6 à 0 exactement
[Musique]
c'est terminé sur ce score de
[Applaudissements]
c'est elle qui aura les honneurs du
vestiaire
[Applaudissements]
je lisais
non et
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici dans ce petit village de la
drôme que maeva a chaussé ses premiers
crampons
[Musique]
c'est aux premiers crampons
son père qui l'a toujours soutenu à
conserver tous les souvenirs de ses
débuts dans sa menuiserie
moi c'était c'était se regardent jamais
ça lui évoqué coes regard où
tu vas avoir de l'envié l'envié d'avoir
envie
tu vois là
je me rappelle de tous hommes et comme
on est petit tu vois tu es petit maxime
et anthony hausse et au maire la somair
ag boula trop barbie que cette
commande est plutôt des fusils s'amuser
avec avec wilco dès que des garçons
après elle a voulu une moto une
cinquante
cross après la boule une 125
oui c'était oui c'était pas je vais
demander par des sacs à moi mais voilà
c'était pas pour poupée barbie c'est sûr
que je prenne s'était fait mine avait
été très minime bien sûr efféminé
mais c'était ça ouais j'avais le temps
du bonheur et au delà nous nous sentons
des suspects west harvey 17 et basse et
je pense avant les face au premier tour
on a eu chaud voulons jouer avec les
cheveux détachés ouais ouais j'ai mis du
temps avant de décider de ma tâche et je
peux manger je m'étais juste une
barétous filage avait des coaches qui me
demandaient de les attacher donc
abandonné voilà fallait écouter leur
coach oui il ya eu les cheveux détachés
par souci l'estany l'ag du groupe jeu
freeze et
j'ai tourné un petit complexe au niveau
de mes oreilles donc c'est vrai que
voilà je me fous un peu
j'ai toujours peur de me détacher les
cheveux plutôt que tu me les attacher
mais bon voilà ça c'est ça c'est les
fils bonjour quelque chose à redire
alors l'effort c'est un exemple enfin
pourra aussi d'être moi aussi fort
voilà
onze
pourquoi tu te sers exemple bas puisque
d'autres arriver au stade où elle est
arrivée là ça royan fin tombe rêve d'y
arriver
du chou qui me
met mal n'ont pas jamais comme ça
mais c'est
[Musique]
dans l'atelier qu'il va pas commencer
maman c'était à 8 ans 8 ans et demi dans
le mmy devant
ils ont agrandi j'en fais des nouveaux
vestiaires avec des douches là bas sinon
maeva changer se changer se changer ici
une petite porte qu'elle a des
vestiaires cyclades de vestiaire d avis
qu il y avait des vestiaires y avait ce
dégât et puis moi je me change et sur
celle sur la salle si moi j'avais un
vestiaire un grand desservant dans tout
ça ici
puis il était à côté
restait c'était marrant mais vous mettez
le à paul pays welsche essieux j'étais
assez riche
[Applaudissements]
mais en fait on aurait dû mettre les
crampons en fait à venir
[Musique]
grapel je sais plus donc avec je crois
que c'était avec saint maurice que tu
jouer et quand sur au milieu de terrain
le jeune homme qui fait non c'était avec
les plus jeunes qui fait ben non il y
avait tiré gaudin à l'époque qui fait ou
la poule il ya une fille qui rappelle
alors moi je me rappelle et moi j'étais
à côté de l'entraîneur et le gamin il
essayait de passer ma y va il essayait
il se faisait dribbler
il n'y est pas arrivé il n'a pas fait
son match du tout et donc il a demandé à
sortir et les sorties du stade ampleur
et son entraîneur lui avait dit alors tu
as vu la fille
voilà
maeva est une des seules joueuses de
l'équipe de france qui continue à
travailler elle est architecte elle sait
qu'une carrière est courte et que tout
peut s'arrêter du jour au lendemain
c'est vrai que c'est un sujet ça va
c'est moi j'ai de l'admiration par mme
ayala pour tous avant de mener de front
deux trucs je suis dépendant chose que
je t'ai dit je sais pas si en première
division de football à vérifier un je me
trompe peut-être mais a même je pense
même pas à l'échelle française many
chaînes européennes
si on trouve quelqu'un qui fait à la
fois une carrière en première division
et en même temps qui est bac + 5 au
niveau ingénieur architecte
professionnellement comme ça qui en
pratiquant son activité sincèrement je
vous non mais je viens demander d'amener
le sport je vais pas en faire encore dix
ans donc à haut niveau en tout cas donc
je profite de ces dernières années de
sport en pur on a eu la chance de
pouvoir être footballeuse et voilà mais
le comment dire avant s'est élargi en
priorité maintenant c'est le foot je
sais que ça serait un ca serait
inversement voilà ça je sais comment
comment ça va se passer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui elle a invité deux copines
football aux comme elle a partagé son
samedi soir à la maison
ambiance calme et sans excès j'avoue je
n'ai pas une grande piste donc je
m'inspire de
d'internet ou des applis
c'est une sauce au miel crèche
là c'est un site
faut pas faire confiance non cuisine
cuisine
away show cuisine étudiants
week-end pas forcément des vocal permet
comme moi c'est pas de s'amuser
bref valeur c'est à dire je voyais des
gens
habillés dans la rue qui allait sortir
et j'ai pensé à dimanche on a eu notre
vie quoi
mais c'est bien aussi parce que du coup
on ne peut pas en profiter souvent donc
quand on en profite un peu plus bien et
voilà
on sélectionne peut dire qu'on n'a pas
une vie de débauche et c'est bien
franchement il ya eu des périodes où
quand même si faut le dire voilà des
parédous quand tes potes qui font pas
forcément de foot bah oui voilà ils
sortent et touba toi tu fais le début de
la soirée et puis après tu veux après tu
vas te coucher quoi donc il ya eu des
fois aussi où c'était un petit peu
frustrant c'est vrai surtout en mode
adolescence tu vois genre jusqu'à
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à 20 ans 18 10 19
et puis après bon
après tu te rends compte que c'est
important en fait de faire en sorte de
coucher tôt et tout pour être enfin que
tu t'adaptes tu prends le rythme
elles ont beau être professionnel et
jouer en première division leur salaire
est loin d'égaler celui des hommes en
moyenne elles gagnent entre 2000 et 4000
euros
toutes ont préparé leur reconversion
c'est sûr que nous étant petit on ne
sait pas on va pouvoir vivre de notre
passion
j'y vais pas leaders sont bientôt -
hoyaux devenir footballeur il pensait
vraiment et même
s'ils pouvaient ils pouvaient subvenir à
leurs besoins
[Musique]
vainqueur avec avec le fond de court
mais nous ne vais pas écrire
c'est la fiche des métiers n'a que tu
veux faire quand tu es quand tu es jeune
à l'école et qu'il aimait tirer sur nous
parce que nous l'après carrière on peut
pas du tout géré comme les garçons et du
coup c'est beau en fait d'entendre des
petites dire je vais être footballeuses
mais moi je trouve que c'est aussi un
peu dangereux défaut puisque il faut il
faut juste noter et leur faire
comprendre que faudra qu'elle est un
métier à vrai qu'il faut pas lâcher les
études citées footballeuses en effet
faudra que tu es dans ta vie tes deux
métiers quoi c'est sarah 2000 j'ai prêté
mon public amoureux césar bruit les
veaux ses programmes après
d'après la carte
et moi j'ai un diplôme de journaliste
donc
c'est pas celle d'incarner un prendre
votre place
moi j'ai diplômés en ressources humaines
donc
je me vois non 5 6 ans quitte d'ailleurs
d'un groupé aux malades et à la non
franchement un haydn dont je rêve de mon
après carrière
franchement j'ai hâte d'aller d'aller
travailler vraiment j'ai vu que j'aime
ce que l'on fait j'aimerais c'est
lorsque tu sais que tu vas aimer ce que
tu as aimé et j'ai hâte de voir ce qui
va maintenant être fixée c'est compliqué
le monde du travail mais bon j'aime at
c'est ça
je suis madame sissoko jeu les trois
doivent oser et puis comment je fais
comment je fais quand j'ai imposé en pas
ma semaine
julie
en avril dernier à 60 jours du coup
d'envoi présentation du nouveau maillot
que vont porter les joueuses
les tournages avec les sponsors qui
investissent de plus en plus le foot
féminin
une attractivité grandissante les grands
clubs comme lyon ou paris sont capables
d'aligner pour leur meilleure joueuse
des salaires autour de 30000 euros par
mois
c'est mieux qu'il ya dix ans mais c'est
à des années lumière de ce que gagnent
les hommes pour toi un modèle réussi
pour la france est un trophée
joueur mondial à domicile pour toi c'est
quelque chose d'énorme
[Musique]
un
jeu de foot gagnent 100 fois moins qu'un
joueur
assez normal ou scandaleux je dirais que
c'est normal
vu qu'on rapporte 1000 fois moins qu'un
joueur gère même qu'on est très bien
payé
non mais ça c'est un faux débat pour moi
parce que l'économie autour du foot
féminin est tellement
incomparable à l'heure actuelle moi j'ai
pas envie de gagner la même chose que
kylie un mba paix
parce que c'est pas possible donc en
fait si je
c'est autre chose pour moi on n'a pas
dans le même monde
donc quand on y sera oui aujourd'hui
gentil on n'est pas dans leur univers on
a notre propre écosystème qui en train
de se développer et avec je trouve une
évolution positive des salaires qui sont
positifs en fait
je pense que pour il n'y a pas une
histoire de comparaison à faire
[Musique]
fiona alias affiche
la plus forte au cuir file ciseaux
[Musique]
quatrième match de préparation à auxerre
face au japon et comme un air de france
98 la rencontre se joue à guichets
fermés jamais le foot féminin nour a été
aussi populaire écoutez savourer vous
regardez ses propres abo l'équipe de
france féminine belle ambiance très
mixte du stade de l'abbé deschamps c'est
l'inspecteur
mais encore
il s'habille à
galli
pierre marion temps qu'ils doivent s
p500 car la tête
la france se distingue une fois encore
avec talent en inscrivant trois buts
dans la fin de l'action des japonaises
d'aquino ses deux simples
les japonaises égalise
mais c'est eugénie le sommer
l'attaquante vedette et meilleure
buteuse qui remet l'équipe sur les rails
du succès
[Applaudissements]
une cascarino l'attenté la frappe alors
lâché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de kaka tout et j fb
theubet victoire 3-1 match brutus
[Applaudissements]
c'est sa part des victoires importantes
c'est bien
je suis fière de ma vie s'écoule
[Musique]
eugénie le sommer c'est un peu dans le
style de jeu le pendant féminin
d'antoine griezmann
elle a tout gagné avec son club de lyon
championnat de france coupe de france
ligue des champions il ne manque qu'une
ligne à son palmarès
un titre en bleu
quand j'étais petit j'étais plutôt on va
dire plutôt garçon manqué puisque
j'étais fait toujours que je sois
billets en condition pour jouer au foot
donc j'avais forcément les baskets et
fallait pas quels choix dans une tenue
inappropriée donc la société jogging
sosthène
général après j'étais
j'étais quelqu'un qui aimait bien
s'amuser qui aimait bien jouer qui avait
la passion la passion du foot quoi au
fait grimper au kilo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est en bretagne qu'elle a grandi au
milieu de huit frères et soeurs
[Musique]
sa mère elle même ancienne joueuse
amateur a tout fait pour tenter de la
dissuader de jouer au foot mais c'était
sans compter sur l'obstination de génie
génie ce cas particulier parce que je
pense que il n'ya pas beaucoup comme
elle qui ont commencé avec un ballon à
l'âge de 18 mois
est serré le ballon
le prendre par tout halal est est en
fait
se désintéresser de tout ce qu'il y
avait à côté comme jeu comme
divertissement quoi il y avait que le
ballon et le gros ballon par la petite
balle de
devant le gros ballon de foot c'était le
ballon de foot qui l'intéressent les
autres
et de faire
des commandes et caprices ce que c'est
vraiment des caprices à l'âge de deux
ans
pour avoir des chaussures de foot c'est
qu'aucun de mes enfants on a fait ça
avant et j'ai j'ai été sidéré corps
elle même avait joué et
voilà il trouvait pas forcément d'avenir
là dedans et c'est que j'allais plus
subir les critiques autre chose que ça
va être
difficile parce qu'elle avait elle avait
trouvé ça difficile pour elle parce que
c'était c'était compliqué d'être
unifiées joue au foot à son époque sa
mère une pionnière qui jouera vannes
cuisent à lorient en amateur jusqu'à
l'âge de 40 ans une passion qu'elle
partagera avec son mari malade sortie de
l'église l'idée des ballons c'est elle
pour pratiquer ce sport elle a traversé
des moments difficiles
à ce moment là il fallait rentrer dans
le moulin il fallait bien s'habiller
fallait être moi je sais quand on allait
à l'école on était bien habillé il n'y
avait pas de gestes déplacés moi j'étais
chez les religieuses attention éducation
j'ai été avec les uniformes
donc il fallait se tenir à carreau un la
moindre chose c'était une colle et
d'ailleurs là l'école que j'ai eu moi
c'est quand j'ai tapé dans le ballon
avec le pied un ballon de volée
réflexe j'ai eu d'école avec ça
moi j'ai des bons souvenirs le seul
regret que j'ai c'est que c'était pas
pris au sérieux quoi quand je disais moi
je travaillais à ce moment là quand
j'arrivais le lundi matin au travail et
je disais que j'avais perdu j'avais joué
au foot tout le monde est fier de moi
pas
c'était la risée de jeter la risée du
bâtiment ah ouais
ouais on était des bêtes curieuses
revenez nous voir pour pour rigoler en
fait
roger doucet
c
et force d'insister elle a vraiment vu
que c'était ce que je voulais faire et
moi j'ai pas lâcher le morceau et du cou
du coup elle a fini par accepter
lumières à l'entraînement étaient déjà
prêtes à partir
c'était marrant c'était copeaux ouais
c'est là je dis assez sa passion elle
préfère aller au foot qu'elle est aux
anniversaires elle boycotter tous les
anniversaires des mercredis refusait et
voulait pas et boycottait même les
réunions de famille pour aller faire les
tournois ah ouais elle voulait pas venir
aux réunions de famille alors les gens
des fois ils sont allés où j'ai mis la
petite allée ou là les palois gênant
elle est un tournoi très tôt je me suis
donné les moyens de réussir et très tôt
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu en faire mon
métier en fait même si ça n'existait pas
mais je me disais va je vais au bout de
mon rêve et je me donne les moyens de
réussir finalement et
voilà c'était c'était pour moi une
évidence
c'est une chance qu'elles ont les films
maintenant parce qu'elles sont reconnues
c'est un sport qui est reconnu
qu'avant c'était s'était même pas un
sport c'était c'est un jeu quoi vous
êtes vous êtes contente de vous êtes
trompés justement à cette époque de vous
ah oui oui oui vous êtes d'imagés pas je
reste est à dire que moi j'ai pas
c'est pas voulu croire parce que c'était
c'était utopique quoi
je suis né trop tôt j'étais en avance
sur mon temps parce que moi je
m'habiller en garçon pour pouvoir les
jouer au foot
je coupé mes cheveux tout ça et ça
serait maintenant je ferai pas ce à quoi
j'aurais le droit d'aller je ne cacherai
pas pour jouer au ballon
l'histoire du foot féminin résumer en
une génération entre une mère obligé de
se cacher pour jouer et sa fille devenue
star des réseaux sociaux
outre son amour pour le foot génie
affiche fièrement son amour tout court
elle a même officialisé ses fiançailles
en décembre dernier
[Musique]
j'ai privilégié ma carrière sportive et
je me dis que les enfants ça sera après
j'aimerais bien gagner un titre avec
avec l'équipe de france et ce serait
beau mais non j'ai pas de regret et j'ai
fait ma vie aussi en fonction de ça je
savais que 11 ans une carrière de
sportif de haut niveau salle est plus
compliquée du côté de de ce côté là pour
avoir des enfants mais voilà je regrette
pas ce choix là en tout cas l'homme n'a
pas besoin de déjà d'arrêter sa carrière
pour avoir des enfants et puis 2 2 c'est
souvent dans notre société la femme qui
s'en occupe et du coup bah ils peuvent
continuer à exercer leur activité sans
que ça
un impact et
vous venez d'annoncer vos finances m oui
ça veut dire quoi que vous entrez dans
la deuxième partie non ça ça n'a rien à
voir non après c'est
moi c'est la vie qui veut ça et ça
empêche pas d'avoir une vie de couple
par contre mais
mais voilà
la plupart des joueuses met un terme à
leur carrière pour pouvoir fonder une
famille jusqu'à aujourd'hui en tout cas
être mère de famille et joueuses de haut
niveau c'est du jamais vu en france
[Musique]
à
la famille les racines des valeurs
essentielles commune à toutes les
joueuses comme sakina car chaoui la
défenseur du club de montpellier
sa tribu n'aura aucune rencontre
enfin chez
sa
tante
[Musique]
23 ans aqinac harchaoui est
régulièrement sélectionné en équipe de
france elle aussi pourrait vivre sa
première coupe du monde
après chaque rencontre à domicile à
montpellier elle retourne chez elle à
miramas là où il a grandi pour retrouver
ses proches
[Musique]
c'est un des derniers matchs de la
saison ce soir sa soeur et son cousin
ont réuni toute la famille
[Applaudissements]
on est une tribu de garçons et on a
partagé pendant au moins un premier
terrain 4 à 6 elles nous représentera qu
on présente la famille habitait star
espère ben oui maman vois tu le sais pas
depuis le temps on court la petite
fierté quand même
chez les quarts chaoui on aime les
grandes réunions
[Musique]
ses parents d'origine berbère sont
arrivés en france dans les années 80
pour travailler comme ouvrier agricole
ils sont aujourd'hui à la retraite
sakina est issu d'une fratrie de onze
frères et soeurs
avec
ma mère l'ami jacques et sa fille
sabrina et un jour toutes et tous en
tête avec les garçons tout ça et jours
quelques mois après nous a forcés
il nous a inscrits de force du coup bah
on voulait pas y aller on dit on aller
aux entraînements mais en fait on allait
jouer avec les garçons dans le quartier
tout jusqu aujourd hui 10 attrapés qui
nous a démonté je vous à démonter la dit
moi je vous pas une licence et ton vis à
vis maintenant tous du coup des prix ce
jour là on s'est calé aux entraînements
et on s'est régalé et après on a pris du
plaisir à jour en fait c'est comme ça
que ça serait pour moi cinquième pour
moi
ce qui me fatigue d'ailleurs moi je la
regarde à la télé ces gens qui y suis
fatigué pour elle
ou de la petite cousine est
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
vraiment
[Musique]
c'est la base comment des neveux et
nièces
[Musique]
bonjour pas dans le podium et versa
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le lendemain elle nous emmène dans le
quartier de son enfance
miramas à 30 kilomètres de marseille
c'est là qu'elle fait ses débuts sur le
terrain elle aussi seule fille parmi les
garçons
elle y jouera deux saisons avant
d'intégrer le club de montpellier
mon
je redescends trouvait là le quartier
c'était la partie avant quartier
terrains
non bâtis mois était là il est plein de
me lancer dans la bataille d'alger il y
avait 3 3 4
avec les retours en anglais ont battu
mardi des bâtiments
vous êtes venus pour voir la destruction
tous venus pour la destruction
c'était comme si on nous arracher
quelque chose que c'était tout à coup on
peut rêver c'est une autre paire savoir
quand le coeur
des cultures vingt ans après le temps
maintenant le terrain
[Musique]
c'était la guerre ma cité
c'était franchement fait c'était
une galère positif c'est compliqué
encore expliqué mais
mais bon c'est là en fait où
il ya des valeurs qui se crée il a des
valeurs et la solidarité
on est toujours ensemble je m'en
rappelle à la supérette en achetant les
chinois on pouvait se partager à 6 quoi
donc donc ouais c'était vraiment c'est
grâce à ça que j'ai eu des valeurs très
fort j'ai des valeurs que je encore
actuellement ok
donc situe à l'éducation et aux gens qui
nous entourent et tout au long de notre
enfance mon coeur
voilà
là c'était vraiment le terrain du som
ces personnes voulaient perdre tout le
monde voulait gagner l'homme était en
gp2 asie séries wheels a joué sans vie
en
fin de journée les filles de la famille
joue contre les garçons mais sakina
reste spectatrice pour ne pas risquer de
se blesser
2 0 enfin ça joue les vieux même si
l'écart chaoui fils jouer
surtout cette famille je crois
on
[Musique]
[Rires]
voulait quand même
nous entrant vous estimez attendait ce
clash la kaaba
[Musique]
il j'ai pas aimé la gagner là à voir que
vos enfants ont tous réussi que cette
image
qu'est ce que ça vous de cette histoire
on a je vous suis content parce que
je crois la femme dit
non c'est très lent science et
je suis contente avec ma fille
[Applaudissements]
aussi ah oui et je n'ai
jamais vu sauf
à les contacter aviaire parce que les
commencer par
celles des six a commencé
oui toujours débat
ah oui
c'est bien
quatre soldats
toujours printemps sur leurs sages
voulait beaucoup de travail viennent à
l'école a travaillé à la maison et de
voir tout ça n a pas de wii
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux autres changements du côté de
l'équipe de france l'entrée en jeu de la
montpelliéraine car charlie et l'entente
dernier match de préparation avant
l'annoncé de la liste définitive face au
danemark
sakina fait son entré à un quart d'heure
de la fin de la rencontre une entrée
remarquée la france mène 4 à 0
ap rentrant et elle manque de justesse
d'inscrire un cinquième but
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la france est en pointe à 0
différence pour
merci
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
4 0 sans encaisser de but ce soir tout
va bien ouais c'est mieux c'est mieux
quand on se l'était dit elle et filles
l'ont fait donc c'est bien et une
meilleure deuxième période dans la
maîtrise le fait de marquer très
rapidement si en début de seconde
période ça nous a facilité la tâche
les 23 pour les inventaires corinne
qu'est ce que tu fais
j'ai quelques interrogations encore
y en a pas beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup et rendez vous enlever ça
sera la dernière ligne droite de la
préparation pour cette coupure merci
merci à bientôt
[Musique]
le journal bruno duvic bonjour intro
soyez les bienvenus dans le journal de
13h au sommaire aujourd'hui vous avez
adoré vivre l'été dernier au rythme de
la coupe du monde de foot et bien c'est
reparti la coupe du monde féminine
commence un peu ce soir l'entraîneuse
corinne diacre présente les 23 joueurs
sélectionnés en équipe de france pour
toutes les joueuses c'est une longue
journée qui commence la sélection doit
être annoncé en direct à la télévision
je là je me sens très j'avoue nous
sommes stressés pourtant je n'ai pas
ressenti saturé ces derniers jours et où
tu vois je me disais bon bat façon il
n'y avait rien de suspect à faire j'ai
fait tout ce que j'ai pu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et j'avais pas de stress
mais là c'est vrai que ça fait deux
trois heures il voulait pas que la
journée soit longue du coup se rattache
à la halle agences j'y suis restée deux
bars après j'ai fait tout le ménage il
fait plein de choses tu vois pour que ça
passe là vu que là il ya plus rien à
faire bah ça y est tu votes tu pense
encore
voilà
[Musique]
tu l'as pas laver
en attendant maeva va patienter comme
elle peut chez elle
ce que j'ai fait tellement un truc que
je fais rarement comme ça tout ça j'ai
pris un bain tellement je chante et je
t'ai vite fait tendues c'est con ça a
marché chais pas propre
beaucoup d'éléments jouent en sa
défaveur une blessure qui l'a éloigné du
terrain pendant plusieurs semaines et le
fait qu'elle n'a pas été retenu par
corinne diacre pour les deux dernières
rencontres
[Musique]
mais toi tu en as
moison peut-être un micro doute qu'elles
vont y être un
peu plus compliqué
c'est parti jambes ça fait partie du jeu
il
faut l'accepter
ce soir ses amis sont venus la soutenir
une quarantaine de joueuses ont été
convoqués en équipe de france ces deux
dernières années mais elles ne seront
que 23 à disputer la coupe du monde
[Musique]
personne dans la confiance
regardons si elle dans son combat les
joueuses oui j'ai travaillé c'est triste
avec mon staff mais effectivement les
joueuses vont apprendre ce soir encore
il fait un
gardien de but
sarah voix dit
ce belge durant
pauline permanent
défenseur je lis de gaubert
sakina car chérif
wendy renard
il a tendu
un sapin tout cas
toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant j'attends
de mon frère
ça va me faire d'amour
oui
de ouf
deux franchises redondance
c'est le feu
ces gens je faire
il est mort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
sakina car chaoui aussi a été retenu
tout comme grâce chez euros et viviana
c'est
l'inversé chaque page index
on modifie son meilleur égard jean prat
aux côtés de leur capitaine amandine
henry et de leur buteuse eugénie le
sommer elles vont toutes participé à la
première coupe du monde de leur carrière
et enflammer les stades
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant que vous êtes sélectionné lé
vous gagner cette coupe du monde
bah oui
pas que moi mais le groupe et ceux qui
nous suivront alors on va gagner de 500
pages espérant mais j'y crois
[Musique]
et je garde le papier
être
devant la fenêtre
alésien asseyez-vous juste pour voir si
je pense que ça va
comme ça ou
pas comme ça avoue fait le mélo déjà
ouais vous regarder la caméra
viser la question de branche peut y
aller
alors avec en premier lieu le 7 juillet
au soir votre fille amandine henry
capitaine de l'équipe de france
peut-elle en soulever la coupe du monde
oui ou non oui bien sûr
avec certitude mon plus grand rêve
c'est tout